hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt
heute gibt es ein ganz klassisches
rezept und zwar gibt es einen
versunkenen apfelkuchen
das ist ein rührteig bzw einen kuchen
aus einer masse und da kommen noch äpfel
mit rein der kuchen ist saftig und er
ist auch total einfach und sehr schnell
hergestellt deswegen zeige ich gleich
mal die zutaten an zutaten brauche ich
ein kilo äpfel ich habe zu rostock drei
eiweiß eine prise salz und 50 gramm
zucker 125 gramm weiche butter 125 g
zucker etwas vanille extrakt 3 eigelb
eine unbehandelte zitrone 250 gramm mehl
einen halben teelöffel backpulver 100
milliliter lauwarme milch und etwa zwei
esslöffel aprikosenmarmelade ich nehme
jetzt zuerst mal weiß das eiweiß und
gebt das mit salz gemeinsam in eine
rührschüssel und zwar besitzt vorher
streit geschlagen und getrennt von den
anderen zutaten damit ich einfach die
römer so etwas lockerer bekomme jetzt
als ich das erstmal steif schlagen und
sobald es schneit ist kommt noch der
bürger mit rein
und zwar bewegte sich dann dass die
eismasse einfach nicht ob sie sich
später mit dem restlichen teig gut
verbindet und sobald der komplette
zucker mit drin ist lasst uns die
maschine noch etwas zwei bis drei
minuten weitere habe ich diesbezüglich
bisschen auf wissen kann
die mini hat es übrigens premiere auf
einem kanal zum ersten mal im video mit
ihr
es ist das eiweiß fertig und ich brauche
jetzt die geweihte schüssel und zwar bei
dieser schlüssel butter zucker und
manila extrakt verrühren und dafür muss
die mutter jetzt sehr weich sein
zum früheren nehme ich jetzt hier eine
flachere und wird die butter mit dem
zucker in etwa zwei bis drei minuten
cremig rühren
die eigelbe nacheinander zu jetzt kommt
noch der zitronenschale ab mittendrein
ich finde das passt immer ganz kurz um
apfelkuchen und ich erinnere mich noch
daran dass wir in der ersten klasse
immer neue klassenlehrerin damals auch
apfelkuchen gemacht haben und ich hatte
an einem tag sogar abgestorbener dabei
und deswegen mag ich den kuchen echte
tragen und aber eben aufs letzte traude
mit drin
und immer wenn ich den mache ich mich zu
tragen an wänden der waffe jetzt
verrühren und backpulver und
normalerweise wird bei einem rührteig
sogar fast gar keine backpulver genommen
weil einfach schon die butter und die
eier für die lockerheit sorgen aber man
gibt ganz gerne trotzdem ein bisschen
was mir dazu zumindest jetzt bei so
einem mit äpfeln würde ich auf jeden
fall was dazu geben
jetzt gebe ich die hälfte des mädels mit
rein du es kurz ein dann die hälfte der
milch und dann eben noch mal den rest
jetzt noch den rest ich finde bei der
mini echt schön dass diese schön leise
ist und ich mich wirklich ganz normal
mit euch unterhalten kann
der rest ist noch ganz kurz ein gewinn
das reicht schon jetzt wird noch der
schnee unter gehoben und zwar mache ich
das jetzt auch in der küchenmaschine
denn die mini hat so eine halbe stufe
also dass es stand die unterstufe
ansonsten könnte es natürlich auch
einfach mit dem teig sauber machen aber
die stufe ist wirklich vorsichtig genug
so dass ich das jetzt in der maschine
rühren kann unterheben
natürlich den teig in eine vorbereitete
backform die muss ich jetzt auch 26 cm
durchmesser einstellen und backen teil
jetzt in dem takt bringen weil er dann
einfach gleichmäßiger aufgeht
als nächstes nehme ich jetzt die äpfel
und die werden jetzt geschält und
entweder in scheiben geschnitten und in
den kuchen reingesteckt oder macht es so
wie ich habe hier so eine spirale
schneider und zwar passt er auch auf die
kitchenaid auf die mini aber auch auf
die artisten auf die große und kommt
hier vornherein es gibt auch spiral
schneider die man mit handkurbel so hat
man einfach beide hände frei und jetzt
nehme ich hier vorne diesen schneide
aufsatz da ich auch hier so ein apfel
abgebildet was kommt da rein und jetzt
erledigt er das schneiden und das
schälen in einem den strunk den stil
entferne ich kurz jetzt wird der apfel
hier vorne rein gesteckt und dann
schiebe ich jetzt dieses heil ganz nach
vorne und drückt hier rein und jetzt
muss man noch die maschine an gemacht
werden
nämlich hier die äpfel weg und alles was
jetzt zurückbleibt ist jetzt hier der
strom den man sowieso nicht mit ist und
so ein kleines stückchen was man einfach
so verlassen kann die ft am besten immer
gleich mit der zitrone einreiben damit
sie nicht frauen werden
das macht am besten gleich nachdem sie
geschält ist
die äpfel nämlich selbst und halte sie
und dann habe ich nämlich die perfekten
apfelscheiben so vielleicht wollte ich
sehen wie sie jetzt aussehen
jetzt ist nämlich so eine lange apfel
spirale richtig schön was mir mal in
hamburg auf dem auf dem truck festival
ja als food festival ganz kurz bevor du
weitermachst ich steckte nämlich hier
noch kurz rein und gerade so ein
bisschen reinstecken
ok und da hat soll diese kartoffeln
gegeben also die pommes die waren auch
so in diesem rädchen ja das stimmt
wir können doch das machen mit ding
gemacht hat offenbar das kann schon mal
so machen wie dynamic offenbar ja das
kann zu machen und dann richtig toll
würzen
ok es kurz machen die hat abstrus nur
den aufsatz wechseln denn der absatz mit
dem apfel der hat er hier diesen großen
strunk das heißt er ist für apple damit
das innere rausgeht oder auch für birnen
zum beispiel und du musst bei kartoffeln
wenn du auch die scheiben möchtest also
die spirale einfach den normalen aufsatz
dann hat er nämlich dann nur einen
kleinen strunk und der rest bleibt dann
an der kartoffel dran so diese so
reingehen
er machte weiter und ich mache die äpfel
rein
okay ich mache jetzt erlebten und elaste
kind achten jetzt
ich würde sagen die kartoffeln aus und
die kann man jetzt nach dem rezept von
der cma kartoffeln badges gemacht wie
auch immer halb englisch halt die kann
ich jetzt die kammer jetzt will ich aufs
backblech legen und so richtig schön auf
blechen hof machen
ich mache jetzt mal was dann übrig
bleibt das ist das hier das wäre jetzt
der strunk hier und zwei spitzen
reinlegen risiko mit dem pilz zwei
nummer 1 machte hier ruhig weiter und
bei uns geht's einen apfelkuchen weiter
ich könnte die ganze zeit
der kuchen mitte zum vorletzten backofen
bei 175 grad ober unterhitze für etwa 30
bis 35 gebacken
jetzt wird der heiße kuchen mit der
warmen aprikosenmarmelade bestrichen und
dann muss er komplett abkühlen der kugel
ist jetzt abgekühlten jetzt kann ich ihn
aus der form herauslösen und es ist ja
schon richtig einfacher kuchen und so
ein altes rezept eben ein klassischer
sonntagskuchen am besten mit einem
torten retter gerade wieder trickse den
games company unter dem bug folie kurz
hervorgeholt
weiter und wer mag kann jetzt nach den
kuchen mit diesem schnee bestreuen
das ist der zucker der auf der
oberfläche ist sondern einfach schön
darüber liegen bleibt
aber ihr könnt es natürlich auch sie
läuft schon
diese ganzen gegen möchtest du probieren
ja wir hatten schon lange keine normalen
klassischen komme ja erst mal
aufgefallen
zwar viele torten in der zeit superlativ
ist ein ganz normaler ein harry co und
auch am schönsten ist dazu jetzt noch
klecks sahne
die sahneschnitten kritische reflexion
nebendran ja und jetzt noch ein
also ich zeige die schau ich habe die
sache übrigens einfach mit bisschen
meinl extrakte und seiner park
aufgeschlagen
ok und hier merkt man auch das ist ein
sehr sehr weit gucken sie zu schauen so
richtig schön dass ich den kuchen grad
noch mal riecht einfach nur auge und
zitrone
das ist der super sache sein genialer
kuchen wirklich ein perfekter coup der
ist perfekt das freue ich der teig von
dem wo wir machten war schon mal gemacht
dass nach gemacht was waren das genau
ist frisches ja wegen genau decken
kinder paradiso aber geschmacklich
trocken also ich finde es geht fast
nichts über apfelkuchen mal apfelkuchen
einfach immer gut aber das habe ich
vergessen habe das symbol von menschen
die draußen zu gehen
also wer möchte kann natürlich noch mit
zimtpulver aber morath findet so schon
perfekt mit komischen affront traum ganz
ehrlich so verein schnickschnack freut
sich die wahlen
ich hatte eben in ungefähr 15 minuten 15
bis 20 minuten maximal im backofen und
innerhalb von 30 minuten war es fertig
also nach nicht einmal einer stunde
habt ihr einen perfekt gebackenen kuchen
auf dem tisch und könnt ihr jetzt habe
ich das foto schon geschossen hieß es
viel spaß beim nachmachen bis zum
nächsten mal tschüss